I got a little uh conspiracy if you look
at the lay of the land the most of the
big dogs are taken before UFC 300 and I
have no inside sources I didn't Source
check anything with this but if it's
just what appears what I think this
could line up I think usd300 you're
going to get Connor Chandler and you're
going to get GSP Diaz Nick Diaz
what that one got you guys huh that one
woke you up huh and here's my only
assumption with that if you noticed
lately gsp's posted a a lot more when
guys retire they're usually not that
active on social media he's posting way
more content he's in phenomenal shape
he's supposed to Grapple on December
15th they pulled him from that card he's
just commentating on it now I have no
reason to think this no reason besides
just adding up the Clues here but
there's going to be some big names
that's why I the GSP thing makes sense
to me